all right Jeremiah
so Jeremiah where are you from
originally where'd you grow up uh San
Bernardino California
San Bernardino and tell me about your
family you had both your parents grown
up uh no mainly just my mom
yeah just my mom basically but even her
she was like doing her own thing working
and stuff so kind of raised myself
pretty much
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um pretty pretty rough you know a lot of
people made it seem like I was strange
for certain things that I liked
which other meaning what like uh I had a
big foot Fetter since I was like three
months and then you know that was a big
part of my life three months yeah yeah I
was three months old when I um I guess I
was at um my mom's friend's house and
she was talking to my mom and then the
next thing that she knows I'm sucking on
her friend's toe and it's just crazy I'm
like I'm hearing about this because
obviously at three months I don't you
know I don't know I don't remember but
every time I see it to this day she's
like oh you remember that
yeah so you think you were born with it
uh possibly I mean who knows where yeah
I've looked it up but it says like
somewhere in the brain like like in feet
or something's in there it's close to
the sexual part of it's it's very common
though you know I've been made to seem
like I needed help you know what I mean
I think it's very common yeah a lot of
the girls I interviewed that work as
prostitutes will tell me that they how a
lot of them have clients who are just
into playing with feet yeah so
yeah that's what I'm figuring out now
it's like whole communities about it and
stuff but yeah I mean when I was younger
I've had like experiences like honestly
I was young and then an older girl like
you know she put her feet in my face and
stuff like and just it like even
spiraled even more I was like probably
six seven she was probably like 18 19
you know and like I just told her I
liked her feet and she just
you know started rubbing my my stuff and
then put it in my face and literally my
mom was asleep in the other room
it's crazy and it's a sexual thing for
you yeah it's purely sexual like I don't
do you enjoy that more than intercourse
or something like that uh
um sometimes just because honestly at
the point I am right now I like to do
business more quick look you know and
what I've noticed is like yeah I get
more like
you know like it's a it's a better it's
a better ejaculation you know what I
mean at the end of the day like yeah it
is yeah what will you do with the feet
you will
well I mean it just depends like
honestly like she might be jacking me
off and you know I might be sucking her
toes or
she might give me a foot job or
something
um it just really depends you know on
the girl I might want to look at her
while she's doing it what is that like
they it's like a like a hand job but
basically she's playing with your feet
or you're playing no no no no hell no oh
yeah no I'm playing with her feet but
she's like you know she's choking my my
stuff oh I see you know what I mean so
um there's a lot of different ways the
feet is
yeah yeah definitely and it is does the
how beautiful a girl's feet are play
into it oh yeah yeah I don't it's not
just some people have rough feet yeah
yeah beautiful feet Yes exactly it has
to be like honest for me I love it to
where it's like you know the nail beds
long enough I don't like the little
small and then you know how the pinky
toe and stuff like that like like clean
cut like I don't like really dirty or
anything like that so
and yo
walk around wherever grocery store and
you'll you'll you'll check out women's
feet
it's honestly since I was young like
it's hard not to it's very hard not to
like it'll be to the point where I've
had relationships in there they know and
they're like stop looking at other girls
feet like they get I'm like it's just
feet but they're like you like it though
so it's like why would you you know if
they feel like it's cheating just as
much I mean I guess in a sense but yeah
like honestly that's why I take off my
glasses a lot of times because my
glasses are on it's like a center like
like for example I had like a box
in Houston California
's every girl has amazing feet like it's
ridiculous like because it's not common
for me because most of the girls I've
dated have ugly feet like it's very very
rare if a female has beautiful feet like
not everybody does and that's the thing
because I remember I tell a girl I got a
foot fetish and she put her foot in my
face I'm like oh your feet are ugly I
don't really so would you prefer
a girl who's
um
maybe not so beautiful but has amazing
feet or a girl who's really
spectacularly beautiful related truth
um the mother of my first kid it was
like that she got a kid off me because
I've never seen a pair of feet like hers
ever and she just for me it's a thing
because most girls make it make it like
weird like oh you're weird like one time
I told a girl like she really liked me I
told her like like I like your feet like
I want to see your feet I never never
wore sandals nothing
and it's like she never talked to me
never answered before I hit her up Oh
wrong number you know what I mean I'm
like damn okay this then this girl it
was like encouraged like go ahead do it
you know what I mean like and it's like
my whole life I've been made to feel
weird and then it's like that's the best
looking pair and then you're doing all
that
That's How Strong it was a lot of the
sex workers that I'll interview and have
told me off camera that their foot
fetish clients are their favorites yes
because they treat them the best they
pay them the best yeah they really take
care of them definitely I mean yeah I've
I've you know I definitely don't
pay for it but because there's so many
females like I've found that me as
miyama I'm an attractive man or whatever
like most girls like I go to the mall
most girls are just looking at me and
they let me do whatever you know there's
probably one two out of ten that don't
and that's the thing like my mom she
told me not too long ago she was like oh
um you need help and this isn't that
because I had relationship problems and
I told her like you think it's weird but
these girls like it most of them are
they don't even like it they let me do
it oh if that's what you want to do like
I asked me not in your feet is that what
if that's what you want to do like I'm
like
all right like so some people like like
for me I like like when they're
scrunched and you know what I mean
when they're scratched and they're
telling you like like certain times
what I will do is like like I have a
Twitter you know I'll look and I'll see
like there's a thing called a joy a jerk
off instruction
and to me that's better than sex because
girls don't know what they're really
doing you know what I mean so if a girl
really knows what she's doing like I've
had a few that have tried to learn and
watch videos so they can do uh what I
would like them to do you know so in the
video girl tell you you know jerk off to
your feet or whatever the case may be
and um yeah this is a lot there's so
many different ways so many different
stuff like
it's it's kind of crazy because some
girls like I see on Twitter like in the
in the foot industry would be like man I
wish somebody would tell me that they
like my fear some girls are like oh
that's weird you're looking at my feet
like I'm just like so I honestly don't
even like to approach them like that but
sometimes if I see a girl feeling me
I'll be like if you're cute like you if
you're amazing right
there's no other way to say it does
intercourse even interest you no it does
it does like you know I like doing
missionary and then feed her in my face
that's like one of my favorite positions
because it still gives me a ride yeah
yeah yeah I still definitely like it
like some some girls like uh one of my
last girlfriends yeah very very
beautiful feet she was like you're not
even gonna want to [ __ ] me no no more
you don't even want to have sex with me
no more because you like my feet so much
and I'm just like I mean I can't like
them and like that too
but um yeah I'm just glad I don't like
like you know other things that's just
you know you don't view it as a a
problem or something that you need to
fix it's just something that you're into
yeah it's not a problem it's
um it's only a problem when like
relationships like when they get
almost like needy because I'm now I'm at
the point now where I'm realizing like I
don't know about the Hope because I'm
working working so I'm not doing my
thing so much like stuff like this and
then
a lot of time I just real quick and then
just go about my business like I don't
even really how old are you I'm 24 24.
still okay yeah yeah I'm still young but
you know I got my feet to explore yeah
that's what I'm saying there's there's
so many like you're skinny there's
there's Plum and it's like I don't just
like one like it's like ice cream like
you know I don't like I don't have a
favorite flavor or a movie I don't have
a favorite because there's so many
different ones apples and oranges like
and you know like a girl I'm seeing
right now she don't understand that you
know what I mean like I try to
not being mean about it but she has
pretty beautiful feet but
it's like The Grass Is Always Green when
I go on the other side I'm like damn
like at my box and stuff
like it's like okay so put it like this
I go outside
right now like I've seen a couple right
now it's
ugly horrible like I said my boxing
event and pretty much every girl who has
sandals on they're
toes are done they're like like my
quality type thing and it just
I'm like damn right so I honestly if I
moved to Vista because that's where
everything is at like do you think one
day that you can settle down to one pair
of feet
I have before
um it's just I don't know how long like
I mean my long has been like three four
years and I'm just like this is because
yeah
yeah I don't know it's it's very very
difficult because like you said like
there's so much out here that I still
think about like damn I can do so many
things you know I mean I just don't know
do you think anything happened to you as
a kid that may have set this off I mean
you you mentioned that you started at
three months yeah for sure and then the
fact that my mom like and my family made
it out is like weird
yeah but will them mixed with somebody
else like when I was younger like you
know it's I feel like that's equivalent
to like molestation whatever they call
it like she just you know she was like
over 18
and supposed to be babysitting me and
then you know what I mean just was like
oh you like what okay and then like
she's calling me weird but she's doing I
was probably like six seven maybe and
she she's calling me your babysitter
yeah my babysitter shared your her feet
with you yeah and they were like still
remember they were [ __ ] they were
gorgeous like
gorgeous I don't understand like why the
hell like because some and that's the
thing like some girls they only do
french tips some girls only do solid she
did some design [ __ ] that I still
haven't seen to this day people know
like most people don't do all that extra
so it was just crazy to me that I was
able to even back that she was 18 you
were six years old yeah and did you
I didn't at the time I didn't know but
if I would have knew oh yeah yeah but
yeah but did you climax no that's what
I'm saying I didn't yeah you're six
years old yeah yeah I didn't even know
what that was like yeah I didn't even
know but I enjoyed it yeah yeah I very
very much very much very much and then
it was to the point where like anytime I
like somebody that was out of my family
would babysit me
I made it a point to like you know try
to at least see their feet or something
it just it was honestly like I I never
said that but like like I would like
like touch myself and be like looking at
their feet you know when they're
sleeping and stuff like it to that point
it was a problem because then when I
realized when I was older I'm like I'm
not a creep I'm not that dude that's
just gonna sit you know but when I was
younger I was like six seven I didn't
know you know I didn't know I was just
like I like this I don't know why
and then I started researching like okay
foot fetishes and this and that and a
foot job and this and that I'm like oh
wow so I'm not a weirdo I'm not this I'm
not okay it's coming all right this is
how you can do it you can you know
because I didn't know what a foot job I
used to think like how the hell
can I get to my like you said my climax
with feet and then I just research and
it's just there's things like them then
people that know how to do it like I've
had girls who have
like worked on it so much to where
they're they're good at it they're
really good at it and they what I like
is when they're laying down and I'm
laying down like this and then they're
just you know boom boom boom because I
mean it really is the fourth hole it
fits right in
you know
so
can you even ask out a female that's
wearing boots
no no yeah it's not it's not
for me it's that's like the mystery you
know what I mean like you're like damn
does she honestly I like I get a girl to
like me first then I ask her like right
there like let me see a picture of your
feet then they know pretty much pretty
much all girls know like what a foot
fetishes and if they've done it like
what is a foot fetish but probably like
maybe six seven out of ten I already
knew what it was and like I had one girl
the one that I told you she was like oh
you're not gonna have sex with me no
more
she did me cold because I told her I
like she and she never sent me no
pictures or nothing and I was like okay
then I met up with her that night and
she had amazing like she knew and I told
her like you knew what you were doing
and she was just smiling and laughing
like that's the type of stuff I like
like stuff like that like you know
you're the business but you're not you
know all braggadocious about it you just
I'ma let him see and then boom you know
so and she was like to the point where I
had her introduced I introduced it to my
mom my mom was like oh you're gorgeous
so for me I'm like damn you're so
gorgeous and you let me
you know so
what's your fantasy what's your dream to
fantasy fantasy are you just content to
just play with girls feet and that's it
or is it I mean it's always a fantasy is
it growing and expanding into other
dude just just the colors the way that I
do it like I've tried to do it in the
car before it doesn't really work out
too good
um tied away bigger girls smaller girls
shorter girls taller girls
I found with taller girls is like
certain things you can do with short
girls you can't do you know what I mean
the same thing vice versa and in the end
it's probably not as satisfying for the
for the for your partner unless unless
you're doing other things as well well
yeah yeah and that's the thing like so
that's why I just honestly
like I'll tell you know if I do meet up
with somebody and I'll tell them like
let's just kick it for a second
sometimes you know I try to get somebody
that just enjoys my time and then they
got good feed then I might you know bust
right there and then go up on my bed
like I've had it to where like
I like video calls too so like I've had
girls where they do whatever I want on
the video calls and then
um yeah just set the phone up put their
feet up they're scrunching it and then
boom you you mentioned at the beginning
of our talk that there's something in
your brain that that
well I I was reading something I don't
know the specifics but it was saying
something about like how fetish and foot
but liking feet is somewhere like close
to the brain of where the sexual and you
know your organs are at and it's like
right there like to like fiends it was a
whole article about it when I was
younger I read it and so I seen it again
probably like maybe three four months
ago
that too I've heard my uncle has
um I overheard one time my uncle was
asking my my aunt about something with
her oh my aunt got her feet done she was
showing them but I I asked my mom and
mom was like oh no he doesn't have a
fetish but I think my uncle has a fetish
yeah
so and honestly my dad I don't even know
my biological dad so
but yeah definitely think it's genetic
definitely
very interesting yeah
all right Jeremiah thank you so much for
sharing your story on on your foot
fetish yeah yes sir thank you I wish you
the best of luck out there have fun this
weekend yes sir thank you thank you